[Musik]
bild breaking news
in westfalen herr scholz die fangen
meine damen und herren doch ist das jahr
22 nicht ganz alt geworden und deshalb
möchte ich auch an dieser stelle noch
einmal die besten wünsche für das neue
jahren sie alle übermitteln und
gleichzeitig ist mir wichtig hier dank
auszusprechen viele haben mitgeholfen
das wir über die zeit gekommen sind wir
haben regeln fest gesetzt aber es haben
sich eben auch sehr viele diese regeln
gehalten ja das genau vergleicht wird
feststellen dass deutschland sicher in
europa zu den ländern zählt die mit die
präzisesten und weitreichendsten kontakt
beschränkung regeln festgelegt haben
aber auch mit unten konsequenzen wenn
wir das infektionsgeschehen betrachten
wir können das sehen den krankenhäusern
weg haben auch entsprechende nachrichten
aus vielen vielen anderen konsequenzen
desinfektions geschehens in den letzten
tagen sehen können und trotzdem obwohl
die lage durch all die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben besser ist als man
befürchten musste wissen wir dass die
neue nikon variante dazu führen wird
dass die infektionen zunehmen werden und
wir werden in den nächsten tagen und
wochen auch größere zahlen sehen als wir
sie heute schon erkennen können dass
wissend es ist notwendig dass wir uns
darauf vorbereiten dass die
infektionszahlen steigen werden und dass
wir alle notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen
genau darüber haben wir uns unterhalten
und verständigt heute in dieser
konferenz aber was mir wichtig ist auch
die ganze zeit über schon zwischen den
tagen und anfang des jahres hat
intensive beratungen gegeben
mit hilfe des rk ii mit hilfe unseres
expertengremiums zusammen mit dem
gesundheitsminister beratung der
gesundheitsminister und
gesundheitsministerin es hat intensive
beratung leben der chefs der nation
staatskanzleien der länder mit
kanzleramtsminister und auch viele
andere haben sich die ganze zeit
beteiligt daran dass wir hier eine gute
vorbereitete entscheidung haben
klar ist von micon wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen und deshalb kann man auch
nicht eine entwarnung für unser
gesundheitssystem aussprechen wir werden
das muss mit aller klarheit und
deutlichkeit gesagt haben werden höhere
infektionen sehen und es wird auch viele
neue patienten in den krankenhäusern
geben deshalb müssen wir uns auf diese
situation vorbereiten und tun das auch
wir wissen alle was hilft neben den
kontakt beschränkungen überdies noch zu
reden gilt geht es darum dass wir das
impfen und bus dann weiter voran tragen
der beste schutz vor omikron ist eine
booster impfung und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir unser ziel dass wir zuletzt
gesetzt hatten des weihnachten 30
millionen impfungen zu erreichen auch
tatsächlich erreicht haben und es ist
genauso gut dass wir ehrgeiz sich am
nächsten ziel arbeiten nämlich bis zum
ende dieses monats die nächsten 30
millionen booster impfung zu
organisieren
alle impfstoffe die wir heute verfügbar
haben helfen und sind gut das gilt
insbesondere für den impfstoff von
moderner und den von biketec beide sind
in gleicher weise geeignet zu schützen
und wir haben sehr viele davon zur
verfügung insbesondere was moderner
betrifft und deshalb bitte ich alle dass
sie diesen impfstoff neben wenn der zur
verfügung steht und sich entsprechend
impfen lassen es hilft gegen die
infektion und durch die umgekommen
variante und das unicom virus und das
ist glaube ich für uns alle ganz ganz
wichtig eine frische impfung bietet
unverändert den besten schutz und das
gilt auch für diejenigen die bisher noch
gar nicht geimpft sind auch die erste
und zweite impfung ist ausgesprochen
hilfreich wer sich schon ein mann hat
impfen lassen ist besser vor den
gesundheitlichen folgen geschützt selbst
wenn er noch nicht den ganzen schutz hat
damit den dritten auffrischungsimpfung
dann verbunden ist was auch hilft das
wissen wir mittlerweile ist das tragen
von masken von medizinischen masken von
viertel zwei masten und es empfehlen wir
auch an vielen stellen die nutzung
dieser masken schreiben sie auch in
vielen bereichen unverändert fort es
hilft
ich habe schon darüber gesprochen dass
wir in deutschland eine relativ
bessere entwicklung bisher haben als in
vielen nachbarländern auch deshalb weil
wir so weit reichende kontakt
beschränkung bisher festgelegt haben und
deshalb wird das auch für die zukunft
weiter notwendig seien also geht es
darum viele persönliche kontakte zu
reduzieren für private kontakte ist an
die beschränkung auf zehn personen
unverändert gültig und für ungeimpfte
gilt unverändert ein der eigene haushalt
kann sich mit maximal zwei weiteren
personen treffen wir haben unverändert
die strenge regelung von 3g im
öffentlichen verkehr und das gilt auch
für theater und kinos im kulturbereich
zweig manchmal zeigt im plus wir wissen
dass unicom viel ansteckender ist als
die bisherigen virus varianten die wir
im rahmen der korona pandemie
kennengelernt haben und deshalb sind wir
darüber ein gekommen dass wir etwas was
in einigen ländern in deutschland schon
gilt jetzt flächendeckend einführen
wollen nämlich dass in restaurants und
kneipen wo man ja keine masken tragen
kann wenn man am platz sitzt und ist
oder etwas trinkt dann auch entsprechend
klare regelungen haben deshalb ist es so
dass wir dort vorschreiben wollen dass
dort nur diejenigen in die
vollständig geimpft sind oder ein test
haben bzw
bewusst hat ist der kann auch dort diese
möglichkeit nutzen ohne sich noch mehr
extra testen zu lassen
das ist eine strenge regelung zwei den
fluss oder gewusst hat ins restaurant
gehen zu können aber es ist eine
notwendige die dazu beiträgt dass wir
besser vorankommen und dass wir die
infektionen besser kontrollieren können
als das jetzt der fall ist
weil wir uns darüber klar sind dass es
notwendig ist sich auf das vorzubereiten
was kommt haben wir uns auch
auseinandergesetzt mit den quarantäne
und isolierung vorschriften die im
zusammenhang mit infektionen dann
eintreten und deshalb ist klar dass wir
es möglich machen müssen mit einer
situation umzugehen in der viele
infiziert werden könnten darum die erste
regelung wer gepustet ist muss als
kontaktpersonen nicht mehr in quarantäne
darauf haben wir uns verständigt in
enger absprache mit allen beteiligten
die dafür zuständig sind in deutschland
alle anderen können nach zehn tagen die
quarantäne bzw die isolation verlassen
wenn dann keine symptome mehr da sind
und diese frist kann verkürzt werden ein
betroffener pcr test oder einander
kannten
schnelltest haben auf sieben tage
natürlich gilt für besonders wohlhabende
gruppen wo viele zu schützen sind etwas
anders in krankenhäusern im pflegeheim
kam die quarantäne oder isolation
sicherheitshalber nach sieben tagen aber
nur mit einem pcr-test verkürzt werden
das sind strenge regelung die aber
pragmatisch sind und die an der
erleichterung bedeuten gegenüber den
heutigen regelung wir haben uns in
wenigen tagen wird sie möglichst
überschaubar zu machen so dass man sie
gut verstehen kann sie alle bekommen im
übrigen von uns noch dieses schöne
schaubild überreicht und interesse
öffentlich zur verfügung stellen damit
man das gut nachvollziehen kann was dann
in zukunft überall in deutschland
umgesetzt werden wird weil das viel
bewegt in den schulen werden masken
getragen in den schulen wird oft
getestet und deshalb kommen wir auch
leichtere vorschriften für die
schülerinnen und schüler festgelegt und
dann entsprechend nach fünf tagen wenn
ein test vorliegt der schulbetrieb
wieder aufgenommen man wieder zur schule
gehen kann
meine damen und herren das alles sind
kein regen sie dann dazu beitragen dass
wir uns besser durch diese situation
bewegen können aber wir müssen wissen
dass alles geschieht in einer lage in
der die infektion zu nehmen kann deshalb
ist es für uns auch wichtig dass wir die
wirtschaftshilfen verlängern die wir
heute haben und noch mal gerade für die
gastronomie verbessern auch das ist mit
den heutigen beschlüssen verbunden was
ist mir zum schluss noch mal richtig zu
sagen dass impfen ist wichtig wir
brauchen weiteren im fortschritt es ist
vorangekommen aber nicht so schnell wie
man sich das wünschen muss die impfquote
in deutschland es unverändert nicht sehr
hoch und ich sage an dieser stelle auch
und bin ich denke dass ich der meinung
bin dass es gutes wenn am ende eine
allgemeine impfpflicht steht ich habe es
schon im letzten jahr als meine position
dargestellt der bundestag wird dann zur
über demnächst beraten und auch die
länder alle 16 regierungschefin
regierungschefs der länder haben sich
dazu bekannt dass sie für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht sind dass es mit
diesem beschluss jahr verbunden ich
fühle mich da maximal unterstützt das
ist glaube ich auch eine gute grundlage
für die beratung die jetzt im deutschen
bundestag anstehen
gleichzeitig müssen wir für das boostern
werden ich bitte dass alle mithelfen das
hohe tempo das wir insbesondere vor
weihnachten dann müssen wir bald wieder
erreichen und wenn uns das gelingt dann
haben wir eine chance besser mit der
jetzigen situation umzugehen als wenn
wir das nicht tun es nicht also an uns
wie schwierig die herausfordern wird die
mit dieser
gesundheitskrise verbunden ist die aus
einer weltweiten virusinfektion entsteht
wenn wir weiter konsequent unsere
kontakt beschränkung durchsetzen wenn
wir weiter konsequent auf impfung
boostern setzen dann haben wir eine gute
aussicht so gut wie möglich durch diese
situation kommen und möglichst viele
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen
die erste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
im neuen jahr im jahr 2022 mit eben zwei
ganz besonders wichtigen beschlüssen die
ab jetzt gelten und zwar die 2g plus
regel und eben die teilweise verkürzten
quarantäne regelung für uns deutsche es
bleiben aber reichlich fragezeichen und
wir wollen über diese beschlüsse von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz also vom
ersten corona gipfel dieses jahres hier
im studio diskutieren mit bild politik
chef jan schäfer und mit unserem bild
reporter sebastian geisler euch beiden
noch einmal hallo auch gerade im
produktionsstraße unsere schlagzeile
geht geradeaus und mittendrin kommen
eben diese neuen mpk beschlüsse die für
deutschland regeln vielleicht können wir
über den punkt zuerst sprechen wo zweig
plus in zukunft gilt bundesweit in
restaurants und kneipen was genau
bedeutet dass jan für alle die die ins
restaurant wollen also zweig plus ist
die regelung die bedeutet das wenn ich
geimpft bin beispielsweise ein oder
zweimal geimpft trotzdem einen test
brauche um in ein restaurant oder einer
kneipe eine bar gehen zu können wenn ich
nicht gewinnen wenn ich und bin dann
kann ich auf keinen fall rein und wenn
ich gewesen bin dann brauche ich künftig
ebenfalls einen test geimpft gewesen das
sind diese zweig beide male mit test
einzige ausnahme ist wenn ich dreimal
games bin also wenn ich den sogenannten
booster bekommen habe dann brauche ich
künftig auch weiterhin keinen test und
kann ganz normal ins restaurant gehen
wir haben vorhin schon gesehen hier in
unserer sendung wir haben mehrmals
zugeschaltet nicht nur die chefin des
hotel und gaststättenverbandes sondern
auch gastronomen die massiv darunter
leiden die klagen die sagen sie am
ohnehin schon 75 prozent
umsatzeinbußen gehabt bisher in der
pandemie jetzt kommt das noch oben drauf
das ist für viele am ende dann der
stecker der gezogen wird und dann lohnt
sich das geschäft überhaupt nicht mehr
also die frage die sich auch stellt ist
wenn ich geimpft bin zweimal oder nicht
geimpften und wir wissen vom rk ii dass
das bei mikron mittlerweile was die
ansteckungszahlen angeht gar keinen
großen unterschied macht ob ungeimpft
oder zweimal geimpft dann ist die große
frage warum darf der eine mit tests ins
restaurant gehen aber der umgebung nicht
also das ist schon eine große
merkwürdigkeit das eine echte spaltung
dass es nicht verständlich warum das so
genannter und fast bedeutet überhaupt
noch vollständiger impfschutz kilian
sebastian auch das ist eigentlich nicht
mehr klar in der app die wir fast alle
auf dem handy mittlerweile haben da
steht vollständiger impfschutz noch mit
erste und zweite impfung aber mit dieser
art von vollständigen impfschutz kommst
du gar nicht mehr rein ins restaurant
und in die kneipe außer du test setzte
ich eben aktuell also das ist noch mal
eine wichtige frage wisst ihr daran
darauf schon eine antwort aktuell nach
dieser pressekonferenz nach diesem cola
gipfel heißt das überhaupt noch
vollständiger impfschutz wenn ich eine
zwei impfungen habe also man kann fast
sagen ohne tricks geht fast nichts mehr
in diesem land bezogen beispielsweise
auf das thema restaurants auf das thema
kneipen aber wir sehen es ja auch wenn
es um das thema quarantäne geht wer
dreifach geimpft ist der kann bei einem
kontakt mit einem corona omikron
infizierten künftig oder muss nicht mehr
in quarantäne kann man sagen der rest
muss in quarantäne und muss sich dann
erst beispielsweise nach sieben tagen
frei testen oder zehn tagen quarantäne
auch da die sogenannten geposteten
deutlich im vorteil verglichen mit denen
die nur ein zwei mal oder gar nicht geht
weil man eben selber nicht so ansteckend
ist und so weiter und so fort wenn man
eben diese booster impfung bekommen hat
wir haben ja jetzt auch in den
vergangenen tagen oft über die kinder in
der kroner pandemie gesprochen und so
was denn da hattest du nämlich vorhin
gesehen dass in dem neuen beschluss der
jetzt heute diskutiert wurde und
beschlossen wurde da eben ja keine
einschränkungen mehr vorgesehen sind
kannst du das noch mal zusammenfassen
davor einmal franziska giffey das eben
sehr schön auch in der pressekonferenz
gesagt sie sagt ganz ausdrücklich also
den kinderschutz und den
gesundheitsschutz über die schule
gewährleisten die sagte nicht in der
schule dass wir sie sicherlich auch aber
über die schule wir haben ja hier auch
bei bild oft darüber gesprochen wie
wichtig die schule auch ist für die
psychische gesundheit von kindern und
jugendlichen und sie sagte das stand im
beschluss gar nicht mehr zur debatte
weil das eine selbstverständlichkeit ist
auf die wir uns hier verständigt haben
also da sagt sie ganz klar etwas was
millionen schülern und eltern in
deutschland sicherlich eine
erleichterung erschaffen verschaffen
wird wenn sie das so deutlich noch mal
gucken ob das eingehalten wird ganz
wichtig daher die fontaine regeln vor
allen dingen für schüler und alle
kita-kinder da gibt es jetzt auch eine
gewisse erleichterung eine lockerung du
hast es gerade schon angedeutet jan es
gilt jetzt wären das für andere
bevölkerungsgruppen nicht so ist eine
verkürzung auf fünf tage also nach fünf
tagen kann man sich wieder rein testen
in die schule in die kita bei kontakt
mit einer omikron person noch mal zur
erinnerung bisher 14 tage das heißt das
ist eine erhebliche leicht erleichterung
vor allen dingen für den schulstart in
vielen bundesländern jetzt aber dann die
wichtige frage ab wann eigentlich gilt
das ding schon ab montag wenn viele
bundesländer wieder in die schule
staaten in berlin beispielsweise läuft
die schule schon in anderen
bundesländern noch nicht oder wird das
noch weiter dauernd tief in die nächste
woche rein weiß man dass steht dann
datum drin in dem papier es stand ein
datum in einer vorlage für diese
konferenz beim thema zweig plus stand
der fünfzehnte januar drin also samstag
in einer woche dieses datum ist
rausgefallen jetzt heiße es kurzfristig
und wir wissen ja dass alle bundesländer
diese beschlüsse erst noch wieder
umsetzen müssen in so genannte
verordnung bedeutet wenn ein bundesland
da jetzt sehr schnell ist dann kann so
etwas auch noch geld in hamburg hat ja
das ohnehin schon vorgezogen vor dem
gipfel holstein auch beispielsweise
genau aber alles andere was hier
beschlossen wurde das muss jetzt auf dem
ganz normalen wege wie es bisher auch
war umgesetzt werden und dann geht das
sukzessive ziemlich schnell weil das ist
ja das was millionen deutsche jetzt
fragen werden die jetzt kontakt mit
omikron personen haben oder haben werden
in den nächsten tagen wann muss sich wie
in quarantäne also da tatsächlich noch
unklar wann die regeln dann in kraft
treten kurzfristig steht im papier aber
noch unklar wird das tatsächlich zum
wochenstart schon in kraft sein wir
haben ja bei bitte online bei bild.de
unsere leserin den ganzen tag über
gefragt was steigt ihr eigen doch durch
bei den regeln was ist da eigentlich
beim thema corona regel insgesamt und
auch bei der frage bei den quarantäne
jährigen verstehen sie versteht ihr
eigentlich noch was dort gilt und es ist
jetzt kein großes wunder fast 30.000
haben abgestimmt bis zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt oder sind bei beiden fragen
verstehen auch die korona regeln und
ganz speziell versteht ihn noch die
fontaine regel jeweils über 80 prozent
derjenigen die gesagt haben wir
verstehen es nicht mehr es ist nicht
mehr so richtig nachvollziehbar
vielleicht sollten wir einmal noch mal
licht ins dunkel bringt zumindest bei
den quarantäne regeln wir machen es
einfach eine dreispurige kann man sagen
gilt wer dreifach geimpft ist muss nicht
mehr in quarantäne wenn er kontakt mit
einem omikron infizierter soll corona
infizierten hatte sonst gilt eine
regelung von zehn tagen und das dritte
ist man kann sich schon nach sieben
tagen mit einem pcr-test frei testen
also wenn dieser test negativ ist dann
kann man raus also das sind tatsächlich
für uns ja dann auch eher gute
nachrichten dass wir wenn wir eben in
kontakt gekommen sind dann nicht mehr
ganz so lange in quarantäne müssen wir
wollen nochmal einmal schalten zu
politik chefreporterin nadja aswad die
für uns nämlich vorm kanzleramt steht da
wo eben die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und ja eben auch gerade diese
pressekonferenz stattgefunden hat nadja
wie es bei dir die stimmung was hast du
da noch gehört wie es da eben bei der
pressekonferenz vorgegangen ist
tatsächlich ist es sehr sehr ruhig es
ist gerade eben zuerst rennen
der nordrhein-westfälische
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst an uns
vorbeigefahren ihm folgte franziska
giffey berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin eben ist glaube ich auch
kanzler olaf scholz selbst weggefahren
wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe also
die mpk ist vorbei die pressekonferenz
ist vorbei
die stimmung war zuletzt sehr ruhig man
hat dann eher sache orientiert
diskutiert es war zwischenzeitlich kurz
ein wenig hektisch und auch ein bisschen
konfus weil es um die allgemeine
impfpflicht und um die forderung der
unionsgeführten länder die allgemeine
impfpflicht jetzt nochmal mit hochdruck
vom bundestag einzufordern
zwist gab weil die unionsgeführten
länder eben in ihrer beschlussvorlage
gefordert haben dass das die mpk von der
bundesregierung fordern soll das haben
aber nicht alle länder mitgetragen und
da hat
npd-chef ist sehr viel gegenwind
bekommen tatsächlich auch aus den
eigenen reihen von daniel günther der in
schleswig-holstein regierender
ministerpräsident ist und auch in der
gleichen partei ist also da gab es kurz
zwist danach hat man aber sehr
sachorientiert und inhaltlich wieder
diskutiert danke
unsere reporterin vom kanzler wo längst
die lichter angegangen sind nadja aswad
an diesem späten freitagnachmittag danke
dafür und wir wollen weiter hier im
studio über die impfpflicht diskutieren
hat er hat gerade gesagt wie der
software hinter den kulissen lief
zwischen der union und der ampel
zwischen hendrik wüst und olaf scholz
olaf scholz der das abgekanzelt hat er
sich durchgesetzt hat und am ende steht
wie bei uns eben unten in der zeile
einigung länderchefs für impfpflicht
aber was ist jetzt mit der impfpflicht
fragen sich doch millionen deutsche in
den letzten tagen haben wir vor allen
dingen bei bild gelesen das wackelt mit
der impfpflicht und jetzt will man doch
wissen warum machen die das nicht
einfach dauert das so lange warum dauert
zu lange und ist man da heute irgend ein
schritt nach vorne gekommen ich glaube
es ist natürlich einfach zu sagen ich
bin für die impfpflicht wenn man sich
selbst mit dem komplizierten
vertragswerk der gesetzgebung dann gar
nicht auseinandersetzen muss ist es auch
einfach zu sagen ich zahle gerne viele
steuern wenn man weiß man wird gar nicht
belangt man kommt da irgendwie ganz gut
drum herum also zu sagen man ist für
etwas ohne sich mit den details zu
beschäftigen das ist im prinzip sehr
sehr einfach das wissen die meisten
länderchefs auch denn sie wissen ja von
ihren abgeordneten aus dem bundestag die
jetzt gerade damit beschäftigt sind
einen gesetzentwurf auszuarbeiten dass
das alles ziemlich kompliziert ist sie
wissen es möglicherweise auch von
verfassungsjuristen die sagen eine
impfpflicht in der aktuellen situation
wo wir gar nicht wissen reicht
eigentlich die dritte impfung für den
vollständigen schutz aus braucht es
vielleicht sogar bald eine vierte eine
fünfte impfung also so eine impfpflicht
dann durchzusetzen das wird ziemlich
schwer das wird ziemlich heikel und
deswegen ist das sind dass im zweifel
wohlfeile worte zu sagen ja ich wünsche
mir dass und jetzt legt doch mal schnell
einen plan vor
olaf scholz hat ähnlich argumentiert
gesagt ja ist auch für die impfpflicht
aber nicht seine regierung wird ein
gesetz vorlegen sondern sollen
abgeordnete im bundestag machen ja
wunderbar das heißt man schiebt das
alles hin und her und von sich weg der
meinung den wir haben ist das wird alles
sehr sehr schwer es gibt eine
verschiebung der debatte im bundestag
ursprünglich für nächste woche angesetzt
jetzt erst frühestens ende januar
vielleicht sogar dann erst im februar
erste gesetzentwürfe und bist so etwas
dann durch den bundestag gibt
expertenanhörung das dauert alles
ziemlich lange
es gibt auch schon stimmen die wir hören
die sagen wenn eine impfpflicht
überhaupt kommt dann vielleicht sogar
erst im herbst also alle länderchefs
sind dafür aber keiner macht sie die
impfpflicht das ist die botschaft dieses
tages nach diesem impfpflicht soft dort
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
wie kann es denn da aber dann trotzdem
sein weil olaf scholz sagte ja als er
hier auch bei bild live war nach der
letzten ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dass er eben für diese impfpflicht
stimmen wird und dass er sie auch ab
märz schon sie sehen würde wie kann es
sein dass er da sich noch so sicher war
dass wir das jetzt schon im frühjahr
machen können also es gibt ja auch in
der bevölkerung in deutschland wenn man
umfragen glaubt doch eine deutliche
stimmung pro impfpflicht und das ist der
wille offenbar einer mehrheit der
bundesbürger die für eine impfpflicht
sind da manchmal stecken ja auch die
probleme genau im detail es gibt eine 1
grundgesetz hier in deutschland
das hat verfassungsrang und deswegen
gibt es viele fassungslos osten und die
sagen es wird einfach sehr sehr schwer
das durchzusetzen es gibt verschiedene
argumente warum das problematisch ist
einige habe ich gerade genannt und es
gibt juristen die können das noch viel
viel besser erklären als ich kernpunkt
ist ein argument beispielsweise wenn
eine impfpflicht kommt dann muss sie zum
einen natürlich auch kontrolliert werden
können das könnte man über stichproben
machen beispielsweise aber es gibt auch
einige die sagen das geht nur in frage
ist wie kommen wir denn so schnell zu
einem free gäste auch problematisch dann
die frage kann man das wirklich
durchsetzen wenn man gar nicht weiß wie
häufig man sich immer wieder nach impfen
lassen muss da sind beispielsweise zwei
probleme einfach mal so und dann ist
natürlich eine entscheidende frage auch
ja sündig dieses land nicht noch stärker
an mir sehen jahr auf der straße was los
ist es gibt eine harte
auseinandersetzung überhaupt um diese
corona maßnahmen so es gibt jetzt schon
schon aufrufe zu gewalttaten die wir
insgesamt auf schärfste auch
zurückweisen müssen protest ist okay
aber alles was darüber hinaus geht eben
nicht so und es gibt auch mord aufrufe
wie wir ja gehört haben auch gegen
prominente politiker in einer solchen
lage in einer solchen aufgeheizten
stimmung kann natürlich eine impfpflicht
dazu führen dass diese lage noch viel
stärker aufgeheizt wird so und das ist
halt auch ein punkt die man beachten
muss noch ein wunder punkt heute in
diesem corona gipfel die zahlen basis
auf der man diese beschlüsse getroffen
hat heute sebastian bild hat immer
wieder berichtet in den vergangenen
tagen über diese dünne zahlenbasis über
die falschen zahlen die da seit tagen
eigentlich das robert koch institut
meldet sagt das institut ja auch selbst
dass man im moment keine validen zahlen
basis hat sondern erst mitte januar
wieder also im verlauf der nächsten
woche so weit sein wird dass man da
realistische zahlen für deutschland
vorliegt also auf dieser basis wurden
heute diese beschlüsse getroffen die
restaurant branche hart getroffen heute
durch zweig plus ungeimpfte sowieso aber
auch teilweise geimpfte aussortiert bei
restaurantbesuchen das alles auf basis
ja nicht valide zahlen ist sebastian
hältst du das persönlich für ganz normal
weil wir sind das gewohnt mittlerweile
in der korona krise oder hätte man nicht
besser warten müssen heute mit dem
gipfel vielleicht noch bis zum 10 januar
bis dann die zahlen wieder vorliegen das
war ja der vorschlag von markus söder
hier noch ein paar tage zuwarten
tatsächlich wir wissen auch es kann
möglicherweise sogar sich in ein
verfassungsrechtliches problem
auswachsen wenn man auf eine auf einer
nicht validen daten basis entscheidet
deswegen ist es tatsächlich sehr wichtig
dass wir jetzt sozusagen auf sicht
weniger tage hier möglichst wieder aus
diesem blindflug rauskommen und wieder
klare corona zahlen haben und auch
wissen was sie uns sagen und was sie
bedeuten und wir auch nicht nur auf die
inzidenz schauen die sicherlich noch
weiter steigen kann sondern auf die
hospitalisierung raten stärker schauen
und auch natürlich darauf wie die
auslastung tatsächlich die
intensivbetten ist genau wir müssen raus
kommen aus diesem wind flug bei den
crooner zahlen und zwar sehr schnell und
im übrigen hat der stolz dass fast ein
bisschen so durch die brust ins auge mit
angesprochen indem er nämlich noch mal
sich selbst im grunde oder die alle
beteiligten gelobt hat dafür dass man
auch zwischen den jahren sehr intensiv
gearbeitet habe und so weiter also das
hat er bisher versucht so etwas mit
abzufragen hatte ich ein album sowieso
was hattest du für einen eindruck heute
von herrn scholz er wurde jetzt nach den
ersten zwei ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen die er als bundeskanzler
geleitet hat schon scharf kritisiert
auch für seine ausdrucksweise wie kam er
für dich heute rüber man nennt ihn ja
seit langem den oder früher vor allem
sollte man ihn gern mal den scholzomat
als der partei karriere gemacht hat
schon in der in der spd weil er einfach
druckreif spricht er spricht tatsächlich
auch druckreif aber er spricht sein wir
mal nicht so radio und sendereihe es
fällt schwer ihm eigentlich zuzuhören
was
genau er hatte so ein zwei momente wo er
so ein bisschen da rauskam war so ein
bisschen gescherzt hat wurde auch mal
gesagt hat man sollte zum zum boostern
eigentlich nicht hingehen man sollte
hinrennen zum boostern er hat manchmal
diese momente man fragt sich aber warum
das in einem solchen in einem so trügen
duktus dargeboten wird er das spricht ja
eigentlich zu seinem volk spricht dazu
uns andere ist ja niemand der da einfach
irgendwelche
verwaltungsvorgänge jetzt da so
abgearbeitet und verkündet das ist ja
eigentlich sehr wichtig was er uns zu
sagen hat ich würde mir wünschen dass er
ein bisschen intensiver bisschen
energisch reagieren würde in solchen in
solchen reden